هكذا اذا يتسلم الرئيس لولا ده سيلفا صارت
الرئاسه للمره الثالثه في تاريخه وفي
تاريخ البرازيل رئيسا للبرازيل بعد فوزه
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه على منافسه المرشح
اليمني جاييير ارسنال الذي رفض ان يسلم
الشاره للرئيس لولا ده سيلفا فتسلمها من
امراه سوداء في رساله رمزيه الرئيس لولا
ده سيلفا يعود الى حكم البرازيل بعدما كان
قد حكمها لفتين رئتين بين عامين واثنين
وعشره وتسلم شاره الرئاسه مره جديده برفقه
مجموعه من الشخصيات الرمزيه بالنسبه
للبرازيل من بينها احد اكبر قاده السكان
الاصليين في البرازيل هذا التنصيب شهيده
حضور الجماهريا ضخما من مؤيديه الرئيس
لولا ده سيلفا من الحشد همم الجماهيري هنا
وسط العاصمه البرازيليه همم البرازيليه
تتخلل هذا التنصيب بعض الخرقات الامنيه
الا ان حفله تنصيب استمر رغم كل هذه
الخروقات التي تقول الشرطه البرازيليه انه
استطاعت السيطره عليها اذا بتنصيب الرئيس
لولا ده سيلفا يعود اليسار الى حكم البلاد
وتدخل البرازيل مرحله جديده من تاريخها
حسن مسعود الجزيره من القصر الرئاسي
برازيليا